the MRNA vaccines
um the the adverse event rate it was one
in 800 and this is from a study
published in vaccine by Dr Freeman Dr
sander Greenland who's one of the
foremost International
biostatiticians in the United States
um Dr Kaplan Dr Peter Doshi they
published this paper in vaccine last
year re-analyzing the initial Pfizer and
moderna safety trials and looking at
serious adverse event rates and they
found an adverse event rate of 1 in 800
for the trials combined Pfizer and
moderna and that is orders of magnitude
higher than any other vaccine that we've
ever seen according to their analysis
most other vaccines on the market are on
the scale of one or two per million for
serious adverse event rates and
previously vaccines have been pulled for
adverse event rates far uh far lower
than what we're seeing with these
vaccines like the 1976 swine flu vaccine
was pulled for a one in one hundred
thousand uh serious adverse event rate
these vaccines according to this
analysis are one in eight hundred and
that and that's not just myocarditis
it's menstrual irregularities it's blood
clots certain autoimmune issues there's
been some new reporting on potential
retinal issues with eyes and whatnot
from the vaccine but but that that is
the overall finding is a one in 800 risk
and according to their uh research
findings the overall serious adverse
event rate from the vaccine surpasses
the reduction in hospitalizations from
covid as a result of getting the vaccine
so on a cost-benefit analysis they found
that the vaccines actually cause more
harm than benefit but we they didn't
have age specific data from Pfizer
moderna so it could it could be the case
and it might be likely you know
depending on who you talk to that the
vaccines on net for everyone over 60
could be net beneficial for that age
group but for as you go lower down the
the age demographic it's seems very very
likely according to this Rock Solid
study that the vaccines could have been
potentially net harmful for at least
healthy people in their 20s 30s and 40s
meaning that
it's it's not that people are dropping
dead everywhere from the vaccine or you
know that people are getting cancer from
the vaccine but that on net if you look
at how many people were protected from
the vaccine you know let's say people
healthy people in their 20s and 30s the
actual rate of vaccine injuries would be
higher than the reduction in serious
covid outcomes there there's some
interesting data by Dr Christina Bell
she's a Danish researcher and Dr Martin
koldorf a colleague of Dr J bhattacharya
he did this he's one of the four most
premier vaccine safety experts and he
did an interesting uh you know analysis
of the different coveted vaccines and
what you know what the um the overall
findings are and you know he in in his
analysis he's shown and then this is
from
um this Danish researcher studies
showing that the adenovirus vector
vaccines the AstraZeneca Johnson Johnson
as well as some of the other ones they
um they did decrease overall mortality
to some degree but the MRNA vaccines did
not
foreign